هنا حتى قسم الاستقبال والطوارئ بمستشفى
شهداء الاقصى يعم فيه الظلام الدامس في
هذه الاثناء حتى الطاقم الطبي لا يستطيع
تقديم اي خدمه طبيه للجرحى او المرضى
الذين ياتون هنا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
في دير البلح وهو المستشفى الوحيد في
المحافظه الوسطى الظلام الدامس قد غطى كل
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى بشكل كامل في هذه
الاوقات بعد توقف المولد الرئيسي في
المستشفى والذي يهدد بحياه عدد كبير من
المرضى وخاصه الاطفال الخدج في هذه
الاوقات لا نستطيع ان نتعامل مع اصابات
القادمه بالمستشفى سيتم توقيف عنها نهائيا
لانه لا يوجد تيار كهربائي في هذه
المستشفى تم قطع تيار كهربائي كامل كيف
سنستطيع ان نتعامل مع هذه الامراض يعني مع
هذه المرضى و يعني فقط سنقوم بفعل اسعافات
اوليه فقط يعني ولكن سيكون ظروف صعبه جدا
علينا كممرض وطواقم طبيه سنفعل بقدر ما
جهدنا ان نفعله ولكن الامور تكون صعبه
للغايه التيار الكهربائي انقطع بشكل كامل
عن مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح وهو
المستشفى الوحيد في المحافظه الوسطى الذي
يقدم خدمه طبيه انسانيه لاهالي المحافظه
الوسطى في هذه الظروف الصعبه التي تمر بها
المحافظه الوسطى ولكن هنا في هذا القسم
وهو قسم الحضانه للاطفال الخدج بات الامر
مهددا ومهدد حياه هؤلاء الاطفال بالخطر
الشديد جراء انقطاع التيار الكهربائي بسبب
نفاذ كميات الوقود بشكل كامل في المستشفى
اشرف ابو عمره لقناه الجزيره مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى وسط قطاع غزه